Hello and welcome
to the Microbiology
Lecture, Bacteria
1 and 2, Structure
and Physiology. This
lecture is divided
into two, but it's
really one subject
because it covers
almost two hours.
We've chosen to put
it as two individual
lectures. It
basically sets up a
lot of basic
microbiology that people
would have in the
undergraduate. road.
These are the session
objectives, the one
highlighted in the
one, two, and three
right here. Those are
going to be covered in
the first lecture
and four to eight are
covered in the second
one. So the first
one is bacteria one
and the other one is
bacteria two. So
basically what we're going
to do is try to compare
and contrast gram
-positive and negative
bacterial cell
envelope. So we'll talk
about these subjects.
Identify and state
the important
significance of
the gram stain,
especially as a
bacteriological tool.
Talk about exceptions
to the gram
reaction, which
microorganisms do not
stain properly with
the gram stain.
And then move on to
the second one where we
talk about virulence
factors like capsules,
lipopolysaccharide,
and how do those play
role on the pathogenesis
of infections. Then
we'll talk about
bacterial spores and how
unique they are and
then talk about the
medically significant
spore forming bacteria and
then we'll just talk
about a little bit
horizontal gene transferring
bacteria and how
is that important
clinically with application
and then we talk
about different growth
environment and bacteria
and also again how
important is that for
a trained physician.
So let's make sure
we first define some
basic terms so we're
all on the same page.
There's a term
referred to as
the cell envelope,
and the cell
envelope basically
encompasses
everything from
the cell membrane
out. So the cell membrane
is part of the
cell envelope,
same thing with
the cell wall.
So again, be careful
with that technology,
cell membrane,
which every cell has
to have, is part of
what's called the
cell envelope. Now
cell wall Not all cells
have cell walls. In
fact, animal cells
by definition don't
have a cell wall.
That's what makes
them an animal cell.
In fact, the only
way we can tell or
we can classify a
sponge as an animal
is because it doesn't
have cell walls.
Plants, fungi, and
all prokaryotes
without a few
exceptions all have cell
walls. And the whole
purpose of the cell
wall, we'll discuss
that later. Now,
in a lot of bacteria,
there are other
structures that may
be present, and those
are all considered
part of the cell
envelope, so if there
is pill, that's part
of the cell envelope,
there's flagella,
that's part of the
cell envelope, but if
there is a capsule,
that's also part the
cell envelope, if
there's an outer
membrane, in addition
to the cell membrane,
that's also
part of the cell
envelope, there's
a peri plasm,
that's also part of
cell envelope. So
all these terms, the
term cell envelope
encompasses all
of this and we'll
discuss what
periplasm is without a
membrane and all those
as we move along.
This is a schematic
presentation of what
a bacterial cell looks
like and so unlike
eukaryotic cells like
our cells, our cells
have nuclei, they
have what's called
membrane-bound
organelles. There are no
membrane-bound organelles
in prokriots, and
so they do have
organelles, for example.
Prokriots have
ribosomes, but they
don't have membrane-bound
organelles like
mitochondria, like
endoplasmic reticula,
etc, vacuoles.
In fact, the whole
bacterium was almost the
size of a mitochondrion.
So everything is in
the cytoplasm so what
the bacterium lacks
in complexity as far
as internally it really
compensates for it
externally because you
can see they have a
coarse cell membrane
that's a must all cells
have cell membranes
they must because that
defines the cell but
a lot of bacteria have
uh cell walls um some
of them have capsules
some of them have
plagella some of them
have pili uh for you
know different reasons
uh pili which we'll
talk about those those
are structures are
basically mainly that
bind to the host cells,
basically, so
for attachment.
PILNDR for attachment.
FLAGULLA are for
movement or motility.
Of course, the
prokaryotes have DNA, but
they don't have a
nucleus. Instead, their
DNA is kind of packaged
densely inside the
cytoplasm in an area
called the nucleoid
and so that's what the
term used, nucleoid.
Remember as we talked
in genetic lecture,
bacteria typically
have circular DNA
and it's super cold
and that involves
remembering the
topoisomerase enzymes.
I just want to take
a little time here to
emphasize the function
of the cell walls.
So cell walls, again
the only living things
that don't have cell
walls or animal cells
by definition they
only have a cell wall
everything else has
a cell wall plants
fungi bacteria that's
pretty much like 98
percent if not more of
all different things
uh so again with the
exception of animals
so why do they have
this cell wall uh
basically to resist osmotic
pressure uh typically
cells have a lot of
stuff like proteins
like acids you know
everything the cell
needs is inside the
cell and so this creates
a high osmotic gradient
and water wants
to come inside cells
and so if it wasn't for
the cell wall the
cells would burst and
you can actually
see this you can use
penicillin and look at
the cell on the microscope
and as penicillin
inhabits the synthesis
of cell wall eventually
you see these cells
deform and then
eventually they explode
because they'll just
take on too much water
so that's the function
of the cell wall
in animal cells
that don't have cell
walls what they do
instead is they use
this like a basically
a sodium potassium
pump to pump
sodium out and once
you pump sodium out
you create a higher
sodium on the outside
of the cell which can
help i mean again think
of it like even in
flooding people can
either make dams which
is what the cell wall
is or they can use an
actual sub pump or a
pump which can pop water
out so cells are not
any different they're
pretty much utilizing
the same thing one
of the most important
uh microscopic
stand in bacteriology
is the stand developed
by Hans Christian
Graham in the almost
in the 1930s, if
I believe correct,
which is referred
to as the Graham
stain, named after
Hans Christian Graham.
The beauty about
the Graham stain is
it's very simple,
but at the same time
it divides most
bacteria into either
Graham positive or
Graham negative. Just
be first aware with
the terminology.
Gram negative does not
mean it's a negative
result. That means the
bacteria are classified
like that. Both results
are valid. Okay,
so let's get into
the steps of the gram
stain, and how does
the gram stain
bacteriologically
works. So first
of all, before you
embark on staining
anything, and this goes
back to some of the
histology lectures, the
first thing you have
to do is fix the slide.
So fixation is
important, that usually
happens before
staining, so even
though it doesn't
mention that here,
fixation always has
to happen first.
If you don't fix
the slide everything
gets washed off.
And in bacteriology,
fixation happens very
simply using heat.
You pass the slide
with the bacteria on
it through an open
flame like three times
gently you don't leave
it there to sizzle
so but you have to
air dry it first make
sure it's dry because
if there's water
it'll just boil and
then deform the organism
so you dry air dry
and then fix so
dry it and then fixation
f-i-x fix and then
you proceed with the
stain okay so now
the gram stain is
considered a differential
strain. Why? Because
it's differential.
It's not a simple stain.
Simple stains have
one stain. The gram
stain is a differential
stain because it can
differentiate between
two different organisms
and so it must
have two stains. So
differential stains would
have a primary stain
and they'll also
have what's called a
counter stain by definition.
The stain may be
different but that's
the terminology used.
So the primary stain
for the graham stain
is crystal violet as
you can see right here
from the name it's
kind of purplishing
color so that's the
first thing you do is
you put crystal violet
time wise for this
it's usually one minute
so you can leave the
slide setting for one
minute with crystal
violet and then you
wash now even though
it doesn't say here you
wash that's always
customary and it's kind
of implied that you
always wash between you
don't put one stain
on top of the other.
The timing for
crystal violet one
minute is flexible.
If you go one
minute 30 seconds
or two minutes or,
you know, that's
not a big deal.
It won't affect
the outcome,
let's say, of the stain.
The next step here in
the gram stain is using
what's called a
mordant. And what it is,
what the mordant is,
usually makes the first
primary stain stick
better. And that's
typically in the gram
stain, the chemical
iodine so iodine is
used second to make sure
the crystal violet you
know stains very well
okay now at this
juncture every cell
as you can see
every bacterial cell
just about every cell
really will stain
purple because
that's the only stain
you're using so
they'll pick it up
now what happens in the
next step is you add
a decolorizer so
you're trying to remove
the stain from some of
the organisms and the
colorizer in the gram
stain is typically 95
% ethanol or although
sometimes could be a
combination of like
isopropanol but the most
common one is 95%
ethanol in alcohol and if
this is done correctly
and we'll talk about
that gram positive
bacteria should retain
the crystal violet
stain so they'll stay
purple while the gram
negative bacteria at this
juncture will lose
the stand and they of
course they don't have
any color they'll be
colorless okay now why
is that um we'll get
into that a little bit
more but just simply
here and the difference
between uh gram
positives and gram
negative bacteria is the
thickness and the
complexity of the cell wall
so gram positive
bacteria have a thick and
intercalated uh so
cross-linked cell wall
while gram negative
bacteria have a very thin
one layer basically The
cell wall is not very
cross-linked, so it
doesn't help it retain
the slide as much.
So if this is done
properly, and we'll talk
about what that means,
again, the gram
positive bacteria will
stay purple, while the
gram negatives will
lose their crystal
violet and become clear.
So what is the correct
timing for this?
Oh, by the way, for
the iodine, it's
usually two minutes.
We forgot to talk about
that. but again,
minutes and a half, two
minutes and a half,
it's no big deal. This
is the step that you
have to be the most
careful of, the
alcohol decolorization.
With alcohol
decolorization, the only way
to do this, there's
really no specific
time. What you have
to do is you have to
grab the slide like
this sideways, okay?
Let's say this is the
slide, here's
your sample,
and what you do is
you come and put the
alcohol, like, start
dropping it drop
-wise, okay? And so
the alcohol will start
washing off the
slide. What you're
going to see here
is the blue crystal
violet running off
the slide. So you keep
dropping until there's
no longer blue,
okay? So you tilt the
slide sideways like
this. Here's the
sample. You put dropwise
alcohol on the slide,
it runs off. Once the
purple color stops
running, immediately you
wash. And so this could
take really anywhere
between 20 seconds
to 50 seconds all
depends on how thick
your sample is so there's
no definitive time
that can be given and
you have to observe
the runoff uh liquid or
alcohol and see once
it turns clear and no
longer blue you
immediately wash very well
and if you've done
that properly this is
what you get gram
positives stay blue gram
negatives lose the stem
okay now to stay in
the gram negatives
in order to see them,
let's say your sample
is just gram negative
bacteria, if you stop
here you pretty much
will see nothing
because, you know, clear
bacteria on the microscope
are very difficult
and not impossible
to see, which is why
we use staining so you
can visualize them.
Then you use a counter
stain and that's
saffronin and saffronin
is basically red to pink
in color and so now
all gram negatives
should stay pink and
gram positives will stay
purple and again if
that done correctly as
you look here on the
right side of the slide
this is what classic
gram stain looks like
you have a combination
here of gram positive
bacteria so these
round or cocci is the
better term looking
microbes and these rod
shaped pink ones right
here so this is the
gram negative and this
is the gram positive.
And typically classically
used here is this
is probably
staphylococci and this is
probably E. coli and you
can tell this is also
staphylococci because
staphylococci they
cluster in these grape
-like clusters. In fact
the word staph means
grape-like clusters. So
this is a type of
staph. Now you would not
know what kind of staph
like Staph oeus, Staph
epidermidis,
Stapophyticus, you wouldn't
know the species name
but you know it's staph
from being gram
positive, being cocci in
shape and also having
this grape-like cluster.
And E. coli is
typically rod shaped and
they usually are
random. They're small
rods by the way, these
are not big rods.
They're small rods and
it's gram negative.
Okay so if done properly
you'll be able to
see both. Now of course
most samples don't
have both and so you
got to keep in mind that
it's very easy for
you to tell the purple
from the pink and the
pink from the purple
because of the contrast
they're both on slide
but a lot of times
if these things are
individually like by
themselves they make you know
like if it's just gram
positive only on the
slide or gram negative
it might be a little
bit more harder to
tell it's not as easy
as you might think so
might be a good idea
for you to look up a
few things like gram
positive organisms and
gram negative and see if
you can get used to
looking at some of it.
So the gram stain is
a very powerful stain,
very simple. This whole
thing we talked about
a minute, maybe two
minutes, maybe 30
seconds, and counter
stain usually one minute.
So the whole
thing is like five
minutes really.
And then you can
divide the
bacteria into two,
which is very powerful.
And in this case
here, you can tell
that you even have
staphylococci because
of the shape and
because of the morphology
and the pattern.
And so the gram stain
can be sometimes
almost the like the
final step to know what's
going on and we'll
talk about that we'll
see that so clinically
it can be very
very useful and very
simple in identifying
the microbe and the
patient may have.
This is a sample of few
organisms that being
gram stand and just a
kind of demonstration
to show you first to
get used to different
gram stands and also
to tell the information
okay so if you look
here on the top right
side so these organisms
by now you probably
know what those are
right and those look
exactly like the ones
we saw before so this
is um what gram stand
do you think these
are uh so this is purple
and the the pattern
uh sorry the shape
first is cocci so these
are circular cocci so
gram positive because
they're purple cocci
circular and the
pattern is grape-like
clusters as you can see
it looks like you know
like like grapes right
and so this is
staphylococci so again we
can tell immediately the
genus here staphylococci
again we don't know
if it's what species
but we know it's
actually a staphylococci
by simply looking at
the gram stain so it
can be very indicative
in that way so again
looking at the gram
stain because it's
microscopy it can also
tell us the shape of the
organisms, and pattern.
So let's look at
this one right here
on the left side. So
these are also cocci,
if you can tell, right?
They also just like
these one, a little
smaller, but morphology,
and they are pink,
so those are gram
-negative. So we're
looking at gram-negative
cocci. Now if I look
at pattern, see what
you're seeing here
see I see a lot of
them in pairs lots of
lots of lots of ones
in pairs okay and so
these are in the
pattern here is diploid
so this is a gram
-negative diploid and
just simply looking at
this seeing the gram
reaction the shape
of the organism and
the pattern I know
that this is probably
the species, sorry,
the genus, Neisseria.
Okay.
It's hard to type
with a mouse,
but you can look
up Neisseria.
Neisseria are medically
significant because
we can't tell which
species of Neisseria
this is, but this may
either be Neisseria
gonorrhea or Neisseria
meningitidis. Of course,
they cause different
disease. Neisseria
gonorrhea causes
gonorrhea, while Neisseria
meningitidis cause
meningitis but you'll be
able to tell which one
right away really because
uh from the sample
you obtained right so
if somebody has you're
suspecting meningitis
the sample beats
cerebral spinal fluid if
you're suspecting
diarrhea you would you
would um get like a
******* swab or something
so knowing where the
origin of the sample
you can immediately
know whether this is
Neisseria gonorrhea or
Neisseria mangelatis.
So again, a five-minute
very cheap stand can
can figure it out. And
so let's move on and
look at the bottom
here. So here are, these
are purpling colors,
so these are gram
-positive. Their shape are
rods and their pattern,
they are in chains.
See how they're long
chains? And so this
is very indicative of
the species bacilli
again sorry the genus
bacilli so again we
can't tell which species
this is a bacillus
anthraxis is a bacillus
cereus is a bacillus
septilus or megatherium
we don't know you
can't tell really just
from the slot but you
know it's bacillus
at least again because
they're gram positive
rods in chains here
too we're also looking
at gram positives uh
purple but these are
uh also cocci so they
look very similar
to here right except
a little smaller
but these are
also cocci but the
difference between
up here and down here
is that these are
cocci or in chains
they are not in in
grape-like clusters see
the contrast so this
tells me that these are
streptococci so the
word strep means chains
okay versus the word
staph which means
grape-like clusters.
So these are
streptococci,
strep chain, cocci,
circular or spherical.
And so we don't
know what species
of streptococci this
is. This could be
streptococcus biogenes,
streptococcus
mutans, and it can
be many, there's
many, many species of
streptococci.
But at least we
know it's
streptococci. We've
narrowed it down
this far. So
let's discuss the
structure of the cell wall.
And we'll point out
the difference between
gram positive or
negative. Of course one
of the obvious things
we said that the gram
positive cell wall is
multi-layered while
the gram negative
cell wall is one layer
but there are also more
nuanced differences.
First and up front
is the cell wall
is sometimes
referred to as the
peptidoglycan. That's
common terminology
for the bacterial cell
wall and that comes
from the fact that it's
made out of basically
glycan, there are
sugar moieties,
peptido there's amino
acid moieties and so in
this case here the
building blocks of the
cell wall are
alternating units of this
N-acetyl glucose and
N-acetyl muramic acid
so these are the
sugars these sugars are
peculiar to bacteria
and so these NAM and NEG
units are bound together
by covalent bonds
as you can see here,
and then attached to the
NAM units are four
different amino acids,
okay, of course, attached
by peptide bonds.
And so this right
here, this is the basic
building block, the
highlighting of the saw
wall. So here's one
building block, here's
another building block,
so to speak, right.
Remember,
the pepto-glyngyme
is a polymer, so it's
made out of pieces of
monomers, kind of like
how you make a brick
wall, and so these are
the pieces right there.
So attached together,
so this is them,
and they're all the
same, nam and nam units
and four amino acids,
and so in the case of
gram-positive cells,
there's five glycine
residues that
connect the two
building blocks.
In the case of
gram-negatives,
there's just one
solid one basically
one covalent bond between
the these amino
acid and that one
that's it and so
there's more inner
connection in the gram
positive cell wall
preptoglycan versus
in the gram negative
okay that's the basics
of it now a couple of
connections here to
things that you're
going to see one
of them is like the
body makes an enzyme
called lysozyme.
And lysozyme is
actually able to digest,
it breaks the bond
between NAM and NG,
okay? Enzymes
can do that.
Penicillin, which,
and you know, a lot of
the drugs like
penicillin and others
work on inhibiting the
synthesis of the cell
wall. They don't
break the cell wall
because inhibited
synthesis only enzymes
do. Antibiotics don't.
This is the largest
group of antibiotics.
So penicillin is
one of them. Penicillin
actually prevents
this transpeptidation
step. So without
this one here, of
course, you cannot join
the units and you
can't make the wall.
Vancomycin also
prevents the nam and nag
unit from attaching.
Also, you can't make the
monomer itself,
the building block.
And so you can
ultimately, in both
cases, you can make
the cell wall, but
of course the approach
are different.
So this is a more
close look at how the
peptidoglycan is organized
in gram-positive.
So you can see we
talked about those Nav
and Ag units and again
they're right here
and you can see the
cross-linking shown
right there in yellow
and you can see it's
multi-layered so this
is like usually just
around like 30 layers
here just showing
like four okay but
basically this is the
peptidoglycan layer
and again like i said a
lot of times the
peptidoglycan layer is
synonymous with the
word cell wall now one
more thing you see
here in um in the gram
positive cell wall
that you don't see in
the gram negative is
the presence of techoic
acids and so think
of this like rebar
so these acids go
uh particularly
like this within
the wall and
provide them with
more rigidity
that's absent in gram
negative so think of
this as more like more
reinforcement and so
it's this complex
structure multiple layers
having the cross links
that they call acid
which allows the gram
positive bacteria
to hold on to crystal
violet longer when you
decolorize with alcohol
versus gram negatives
of course as always
you have to have a
cell membrane every
cell has a cell membrane
and this right here is
the electron microscopy
transmission electron
microscopy of a
cell envelope of a gram
positive showing the
peptidoglycan layer
and the cell membrane
you know pretty nice
detail and this is the
gram negative cell
wall so it's right here
here's the peptidoglycan
layer one layer
again nam and nag
units and cross links
remember the cross link
here is just one bond
it doesn't have the five
lysine residues okay
and cell membrane
just like every cell
has to have some
membrane so the fact that
this wall is so thin
like this gram negative
cells and can't really
hold on to the crystal
violet much so if you
decolorize properly
they use that stain
and that's why you
have to counter stain
it with um saffron now
one thing to a couple
more things to note
here since we are looking
at the gram negative
cell water of really
big importance is
that in addition to
having a cell membrane
which is of course
phospholipid bilayer right
there's also an outer
membrane okay so um
outer membrane right
here okay so this
whole layer right here
is the outer membrane
okay And so it has
double membranes, one
cell membrane, then
peptidoglycan, then
an outer membrane going
from inside to the
outside. Remember,
all this is part of
the cell envelope,
okay, that terminology.
But what is the
significance
of this outer
membrane that is
found in gram
negatives only?
And what is its
composition? So for one, you
see that the inside
layer is phospholipid,
just like the cell
membrane, but this outside
layer is kind of unique.
it's also a lipid
but it's a it's not
phospholipid it's more
of a lipopolysaccharide
so it's a combination
of lipids and sugar
in short people refer
to it as LPS or
lipopolysaccharide means
you look at this LPS
molecule you'll see that
now we'll go into
that a little bit more
but basically it's composed
of three components
a lipid A so that's
the lipid part and
then there's a sugar part
the core polysaccharides
and then this side
chains that side
chain is called the
all specific side chain
and that usually can
be either long or short
depending on the brand
negative so you can
have a oligosaccharide
versus just a polysaccharide
so that just depends
on the species
of bacteria we're
thinking about and so So
this double layer in
gram negatives, and also
this now creates a
layer between the cell
membrane and the outer
membrane, this layer
right here, which is
known as the periplasm,
which basically houses
the cell wall. Now,
the periplasm, you look
at it here, it almost
looks empty, but it's
not really empty.
It's a gel-like layer,
which contains all the
molecules and the
proteins that move in and
out of the cell. So
this is a real layer.
You don't see the
periplasm, if any, in
gram-positives.
And of course, gram
-positives don't have
an outer membrane. So
that's, again, one
of the extinguished
features of gram
-negative. And we'll talk a
little bit about this
LPS molecule. This
is not just the
structural thing that
gram negatives have,
but this has very big
importance from a
clinical standpoint.
Sometimes this molecule
is known as the
endotoxin because it
can create a, it's a
super antigen, so
it can create a huge
immunologic reaction
in the body as a result
of a gram negative
infection. So we'll
discuss LPS and the
clinical significant LPS
in the next few
slides. But this is the
important structure
in different
parts of the gram
-negative cell.
So again, here reiterating
the components of
the LPS layer, which
is also known as the
endotoxin. The endotoxin,
because it's an
internal, it's a toxin
not released. Exotoxin
are actually produced
and actively produced
released from the cell
this is actually part
of its structure so
the influx is not
actively released but if
the cells are lysed or
broken down then these
molecules start um
you know breaking off
and going into solution
and and they can cause
a lot of trouble and
again going back to uh
the structure of the
lpsd components the
lipid A, the core
oligosaccharide or
polysaccharide, and then the
oocyte antigen, which
can differ in length.
Now when people try to
dissect and see which
part of this molecule
is the one that's
causing the endotoxicity,
they realize it's
the lipid A. So if
you just take lipid
A by itself, inject
it into mice, you'll
kill it. But if you take
those other components,
nothing will happen.
So it's really
the toxicity is in
the lipid. And what
basically people figured
out is that the lipid
A can bind to many
T lymphocytes in the
body and activates
them or activates a lot
of T lymphocytes something
like five percent
of the total number
of lymphocytes which
is huge and that causes
a lot of cytokines
to be produced which
cause a lot of tissue
damage and so on and
so people can die
from of course
endotoxemia pretty rapidly
so and this is important
when you're looking
at a gram negative
infection especially
a massive type of gram
negative infection.
This is a schematic
presentation showing
how the endotoxin lipid
A component, what it
does in the body,
so it can activate
macrophages through
toll-like receptors. And
again, if you're not
familiar with some of
this terminology, we
will discuss these in
the upcoming immunology
lectures. It can
also activate
complements, it can also
activate a tissue factor
resulting in the release
here of a lot of
cytokines IL-1, IL-6,
tumor necrosis
factor alpha, nitric
oxide, it can cause
fever, hypertension.
C3A, C5A are a
complement component
which can really
result in edema
and bringing
neutrophils to the
sites, whatever
they're released.
Tissue factor activation
can cause the use
up of the coagulation
cascade. Eventually
it ends up with what's
called disseminated
intravascular coagulation.
There's a lot of
clotting which then
use up all the clotting
cascade which then
results in hemorrhage.
So I
think some gear here
from discussing the
cell walls of bacteria.
Now we're talking
about another layer
called the capsule. So
if the capsule is
present, and keep in mind
capsules are not
present in all bacteria.
In fact very few
bacteria have capsules.
And even strains
within the same
bacteria can have
them now. For example,
some strains of
streptococcin may
have capsules, some
of them may not.
But if present,
that would be
almost the
outermost layer.
Remember, this is also
part of this envelope.
The capsule is a pretty
large area, as you
can see right here.
So if you look here,
right there, this is
the organism. So it's
a spherical right
there so this is a gram
positive okay so this
is like the bacteria
itself and this halo
around it that's where
the capsule is so
typically what happens
this is a capsule stain
and what the capsule
stain does it just
basically stains the
background and stains
the bacteria but the
capsule dissolves and
so you see where it
used to be okay so
here is the like border
mind of the capsule
right there. One thing
I want to just
immediately notice is how
large the capsule is
relative the size of
the bacterium itself.
So this is obviously
a great investment
on the part of the
organism to make such
a big large structure.
Mostly the
capsule is made
out of polysaccharide.
Some capsules have
some protein components
but they're largely
sugary in nature.
but they can end up
with a huge advantage
to the organism
unfortunately not so much
of a good advantage
for us as a host but
from an organism
standpoint from bacterium
it's a it's very
beneficial to have capsules
one of the earliest
experiments I read
down once in the
beginning turn of 19th
century by a guy called
Griffith and what he
did he took capsules
and inject them into
mice and the virus and
mice died now he took
basically streptococci
in capsules on the
other hand, if you
take the same strain
of septic oxide, inject
it into mice that
doesn't have capsules,
the mice live fine.
So clearly the capsule
helped the mice,
sorry not helped
the mice, helped the
bacterium, the septic
oxide in this case,
infect the host,
in this case the
mice, very effectively
and kill it.
So what do capsules
do? So one of
the simplest things
they do, at least
initially, they
allow the bacterium
to stick to surfaces
and they also
allow them to stick
to each other.
So they can stick
to things like unary
catheters, indwelling
devices, anything
that's a foreign body
in our body would allow
the bacterium to
stick to them. They're
very difficult then
to treat or remove
without actually removing
the foreign object
itself. So if this
was a replacement hip
and somebody gets the
infection then you
have to either go in
there try to flush
that prosthetic
itself or you have to
remove the whole
thing and restart the
operation, which can be
difficult. And in some
cases you can't, so
you just keep giving
the people antibiotic
for the rest of
their life to keep the
infection in check.
So capsules, when they
bind to each other
and stick to each
other, they form what's
called a biological
film or a biofilm.
So this biofilm
structure, which we find
by the way on the
surface of our teeth,
and so if you feel
your teeth and you feel
they're slippery and
that's why we have
to like brush them
all the time that's
actually made out of
a lot of capsules and
so the bacteria use
the capsules to stick
to our teeth when they
form this community
of microbes on our
teeth and other places
too so it's obviously
very advantageous.
Capsules also make
it more difficult for
antibodies to act it
also makes the bacteria
more resistant to
complement so I'll try
to include those in
the notes sections for
you in the slide so
resistant to antibodies
highly resistant to
complement and we'll
talk about complement
but what complement
does it basically pokes
holes into the bacterial
cell wall or cell
sorry cell membrane
but of course if the
capsule is there it's
like having a big armor
so it prevents this
process from taking
place all that does
it makes the bacterium
have a kind of a growing
edge they have a head
start because you
can't kill them early
and so they grow in
higher numbers so
it's very advantageous
for the bacterium to
have a capsule definitely
not from the host
they're also very
difficult to clear from
our body the spleen
plays a very big role
in clearing capsulated
organisms and so if
somebody has a sphenectomy,
they become extremely
susceptible to
capsulite organisms
and highly vulnerable.
So before we
remove somebody's
spleen, ideally
what you want to do
is make sure you
vaccinate them
against a lot of
pathogens. They
may have capsules
because then
they will struggle
with that.
Okay, we
discussed the gram stem
and we talked about
how the gram stem
can divide bacteria
into gram negative or
gram positive. So for
one, a couple of
things let's talk about
that. Not all bacteria
are either gram
-positive or gram-negative.
First of all, the
gram- positivity and
gram-negativity is
based on the presence
of the cell wall but
there are some bacteria
like mycoplasmas
and those are called
wall-less bacteria.
They're an exception
to the rule they
don't have a cell
wall and as such
they cannot stain
by the gram stain.
So mycoplasmas
are not considered
either gram-negative
nor gram-positives.
So they are wall-less.
So one important aspect
of this is you really
cannot treat
mycoplasmas with like
penicillin or antibiotics
that target a cell wall
because they don't
even have a cell wall.
Mycoplasma, the
most pathogenic one
among mycoplasmas,
mycoplasma pneumoniae,
which causes walking
pneumonia so if
somebody ever had
walking pneumonia
this is the organ
that causes that okay
um another aspect of
the gram stain so what
happens if you have
an organism let's say
like mycobacteria which
in mycobacteria is
a pathogenic genus
you can have like
mycobacterium tuberculosis
so that's the one that
causes uh tb mycobacterium
avium mycobacterium
lepre that causes
leprosy. So this
is kind of an interesting
genus. It's very
important, highly
important medically, so to
speak, especially with
tuberculosis being
one of the top three
killers in the world
still and actually the
most common disease
worldwide with one
-third of the population
harbor mycobacteria
to date.
So, but mycobacteria
have a thick cell
wall, but if you try
to stain them with the
gram stain, they will
not stain. In other
words, they won't
stain. Neither crystal
violet no one would
saprona they would be
colorless or you
actually wouldn't see it
and so if they don't
stain with the gram
stain but they do have
a thick cell wall so
would they still be
considered gram positive
and so the answer to
that yes and so gram
positivity and gram
negativity is really
more governed by the
structure now since we
have the structure
and we can look at the
electron microscope
and you can see if a
bacterium has a wall and
if it's thick or thin
versus just simply go
on by this thing so
mycobacteria are
considered gram positive
even though they don't
really stain with the
gram stain and the
reason they don't stain
with the gram stain
is because they have
an acid in their cell
wall called mycolic acid
that's where they
get their name
mycobacteria
mycolic this is an l
acid. I can't seem to
be able to insert a
text here to type. So
mycolic acid. So mycolic
acids are unique to
mycobacteria. What they
do is once they,
because they're part of
their cell wall, it
makes the cell wall very
impenetrable. And so
the only way to stain
mycobacteria to steam
with the microscope is
you need to actually
use heat, a lot of
heat to drive the stain
in. And so there's a
special stain for
staining organisms like
mycobacteria called the
acid fast stain which
is a very important
thing i will discuss that
next in our lecture
which actually allows
us to identify
mycobacteria because again
they're unique they
have mycolic acid they
don't stain with the
gram stain but hey since
that's a unique
property why not use it
against them right and
so we use the acid fast
stain to identify
mycobacteria and that stain
we'll talk about more
in more detail okay
But I want you to make
sure you don't confuse
mycobacteria with
mycoplasma. They're
different, very different,
different genesis.
Mycoplasmas
are wall-less,
they don't have cell
walls at all, they're
not either gram
-positive, nor gram
-negative, and they
cause walking pneumonia.
While mycobacteria
is a very important
medical species, they
do have a wall, it's
a thick one, so they're
gram-positive, but
they also have mycolic
acids in it and
you know examples of
this disease causing
is like tuberculosis,
leprosy and so on.
Other organisms are
very difficult to
stain is Tryponema.
Tryponema pallidum is
the organ that causes
the disease ********
and Tryponema
pallidum is a very
fastidious organism. The
word fastidious means
very difficult to
grow. It doesn't like
to grow it doesn't
like the stain it's
just a really peculiar
one and so again
they won't show up
very well with the gram
stain and same
thing with all these
legionella rickettsia
chlamydia bartonella
and lichia anaplasma
species these
are very difficult
the reason also
those particular
group is that way
because a lot of these
are intracellular
bacteria so they
grow inside cells
okay so try to try
to stain a bacterium
that's actually inside
another cell that'll be
very difficult and so
these things these do
not stand very well
with the grafts then
okay but you know they
are they cause a lot
of disease Legionella
nemophilia causes
pneumonia rickettsia
it's a genus that causes
depending on the type
of rickettsia it could
cause anything from like
typhus to some other
diseases chlamydia
causes ********
transmitted disease and
the list goes on and on
okay i'm going to go
with every single one of
them but suffice to
say that these are all
grown inside our cells
so they're difficult
to stand by the gram
stain and they are
what you would consider
an exception to the
gram stain nomenclature
it's a very small
exception we can put
it on one slide that we
have millions of bacteria
so most of them fall
under the gram positive
or gram negative
nomenclature. Again, with
the exception of this.
So we just discussed
mycobacteria and we
talked about how
mycobacteria have mycolic
acids in their cell
wall and that prevents
them from being stained
with the acid-fast
stain, but then we
said they can actually
stain with another
stain called the acid
-fast stain. And so
let's talk about the
acid-fast stain and
other stains and talk
about these organisms
and how that works so
the acid fast stain
the classic acid fast
stain was developed
by two bacteriologists
and so it's called
the zeal nelson stain
um it's a really old
stain just as old as
the graham stain and
the way it works like
i told you um it you
know you have to use
heat to uh to drive
the stain into the
mycobacteria but then
once they pick it up so
you to drive it use
heat and a lot of heat
for several minutes
to get that stain in
and so usually use
carbofusion as the
primary stain and you
use heat to drive it
in and then once it
picks up the stain the
macrobacteria they're
very difficult to
you know to let go
of it and so now even
if you use a decolorizer
like acid alcohol
so it's a combination
of acid and alcohol
which is a very powerful
decolorizer they
won't lose that stain
very easily okay and
so then you counter
stain anything else in
the sample with methylene
blue and so here
it's almost like the
opposite colors of
the graham stain right
because what you're
looking for ends up
being pink or red
which is the carbofusion
and the counter stain
ends up being the
blue which is the
methylene blue but it's
the same basic thing
you have a primary
stain you have a counter
stain you have a
decolorizer in that sense
it's like it's exactly
the same as the
grap stain so if you do
this properly members
that are acid fast
positive would look
like this they would
look hot pink or red
while anything that
is not would look blue
so let's say if you
mix E. coli with
microbacteria microbacteria
is acid fast positive
they call it and so
it will show up as
red while E.coli
would show up as blue
or any other organs
that's not acid facet.
Now the acid facet
thing is the classic one
that's been used for a
long time but currently
clinically or at
least for the last
several years laboratories
no longer use the
acid facet. It's just
you know because you
have to use the heat
and so it's very messy
and people can like
spill it on themselves
and on their you know
lap gowns etc if you
don't decolorize
properly you can you can
have some problems
with it so it's it's a
multi-step process that
can introduce errors
especially if your
technician is not used to
doing the asset fast
thing so if you know
a lot of standard labs
people try to move to
more simpler and more
reliable type of test
so instead of the
acid fast test or the
zeal nelson stain the
the currently used
staining method in clinical
laboratories is the
oramine rhodamine stain
and so and this is
a fluorescent stain
okay and so this is a
simpler stain it says
it's more expensive
because fluorescent
stains are more expensive
in the special
microscope which is a
fluorescent microscope
but it's less time it
doesn't need any
experience you could see it
at low magnification
like 400 instead of
having to go to a thousand
which requires oil
but of course you
get the microscope a
fluorescent microscope
sorry not just a regular
microscope which tends
to be like two to three
times more expensive
than a typical
microscope but it's a
one-time purchase and you
have it for good and
so what how does this
work very simple the
oramine rhodamine dye
binds to only the
mycobacteria because it's
tagged on antibody and
so once they fluoresce
as you can see right
here uh then you know
that these guys are
acid fast positive uh if
they don't fluoresce
then the sample is
negative so there's no
cavistane really they're
just like either fluoresce
or you don't okay
and that's the not
common one now people
use for so if you suspect
somebody has to be
you send their sputum
uh take a sputum sample
send it to the lab
they'll do an oramine,
rhodamine stain, and
report back to you whether
the organism is acid
fast or not, okay?
And there's also now
more application using
nucleic acid
amplification, so like PCR.
So PCR is also done on
samples of mycobacterium,
which gives you a
very quick result,
but keep in mind the
gold standard for
the diagnosis of TB
continues to be a till
-to-date culture. So
even though you start
and you have all these
tools you get the
acid fast positivity
you do a pcr you may
identify mycobacterium
you still have to do
culture you still have
to wait for culture
the problem with
cultures for mycobacteria
is they're of course
hazardous for one second
they also take like
uh six to eight weeks
to to grow the organism
is very slow grower
it divides every 18
hours it's really slow
in that sense so it
takes a while for the
cultures to come back
so you can't really
just sit there and leave
the patient for two
months with tuberculosis
instead of trying
to treat them. But
again, the culture is
still the only way to
confirm the disease,
so that's the gold
standard and must be done.
By the way, sometimes
that's a board
question and that can
come on the boards and
make sure they ask you
what's the gold standard
for identification of
the disease and that
would be culture,
not all these other
ones. But these are all
important because they
give you all this
information and you realize
that this is
important. somebody has
tuberculosis this is a
public health emergency
they can give it to
other people you have
to give prophylaxis
their family you have
to isolate them i mean
it's a real big deal
to have to be so today
it's the one thing
that you guys will
get screened for right
by taking the
skin test just
a quick comment about
the acid fast stain
uh so while the acid
fast stain helps
identify mycobacteria
mycobacteria and
species are not the
only ones that are
that would stain
acid fast. There's
several others including
some fungi like
cryptococci that will
stain positive with
the acid fast stain
and nocardia another
bacterium that could
stain. So having a finding
of acid fast bacilli
on a particular sample
does not conclusively
means that we have
mycobacteria but it's
definitely leaning in
that direction. But it
could also be like I
said it could be nocardia,
it could be cryptoid,
it could be some So
keep that in mind.